c'est normal
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat près de 4000 à médecins
chirurgiens dentistes et sages femmes se
voient menacés de perdre leur
autorisation d'exercer en france
ces médecins recrutés avant 2010 mais
titulaire d'un diplôme obtenu dans un
état non membre de l'union européenne
n'ont toujours pas passer leurs examens
de compétences une des conditions
requises pour exercer en france afin de
ne pas pénaliser ces praticiens qui
pallie souvent au manque de personnel
dans les hôpitaux
le sénat a examiné hier une proposition
de loi qui permettrait notamment de
repousser le délai de passage de cet
examen de compétences afin de permettre
à ces médecins d'exercer jusqu'au 31
décembre 2016
je vous propose tout de suite de suivre
cette séance l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale
relative à l'exercice des professions de
médecins chirurgiens dentistes
pharmaciens et sages femmes pour les
professionnels titulaires d'un diplôme
obtenu d'un état non membre de l'union
européenne
dans la discussion générale la parole
était madame nora berra secrétaire
d'état chargée de la santé
vous avez la parole madame le ministre
non pardon pardon à la ministre a
rappelé le règlement de monsieur milon
excusez moi madame la ministre monsieur
le président je souhaiterais faire une
rectification de vote sur le scrutin 89
90 et 91 en effet monsieur poniatowski a
été déclarée votant contre
alors qu'en fait il ne souhaitait pas
prendre part au vote le collègue a
quitté données de votre mise au point
elle sera donc publiée au journal
officiel et figurera dans l'analyse
politique du scrutin
la ministre de la parole avec mes
excuses
monsieur le président monsieur le sens
de la commission des affaires sociales
je dois messieurs le rapporteur madame
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
madame david pardon madame la présidente
la proposition de loi qui vous est
présentée par monsieur yves daudigny
reprend que vous le savez les
dispositions sur l'exercice des
praticiens à diplôme hors union
européenne
il s'agit d'un texte dont je n'ai pas
besoin de souligner l'importance
chacun a pu évaluer qui pose à la fois
des problèmes humains en raison du
statut fragile de ces praticiens mais
aussi ils posent des problèmes liés à la
fragilisation possible de notre système
de soins
au cas où ces praticiens ne pourrait pas
être conforté dans les établissements
dans laquelle il exerce il était
indispensable de les autoriser à
continuer à exercer et à leur donner la
possibilité de se présenter aux épreuves
de vérification des connaissances dans
le cadre de la procédure d'autorisation
d'exercice je tiens à remercier monsieur
le rapporteur d'audignies rapport de
cette proposition de loi ainsi que les
membres de la commission des affaires
sociales de mal à la présidence pour
leur implication dans l'examen de la
proposition de loi qui vous est présenté
votre travail et les liens que vous avez
établi avec les députés devraient
permettre de concrétiser notre souhait
de trouver une issue favorable à cette
situation délicate et ce dans les
meilleurs délais je voudrais souligner
tout d'abord le caractère consensuel de
cette disposition qui consiste à
prolonger transitoirement l'exercice des
praticiens à diplôme hors union
européenne
dans les établissements de santé
accueillie favorablement par les parties
concernées je veux parler du conseil
national de l'ordre des médecins les
syndicats et syndicats représentant les
praticiens à diplôme hors union
européenne ces dispositions avaient été
adoptées à l'unanimité tant par
l'assemblée nationale que par le sénat
dans le cadre du projet de loi de
finances pour la sécurité sociale mais
elle a été censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel
ce consensus tiens très certainement
fait que l'ensemble des parlementaires
ont conscience de l'importance de la
mesure proposée
compte tenu de son impact sur la
continuité de fonctionnement des
établissements de santé
le terme de ce dispositif transitoire
avait été fixé au 31 décembre 2011
en 2011 le gouvernement a été saisi de
deux types de difficultés rapport à la
disposition qui était en vigueur le
caractère inapproprié d'une partie des
épreuves de vérification des
connaissances et surtout l'obligation
faite à un certain nombre de praticiens
de cesser leur activité au 1er janvier
2012 faute d'être lauréats des épreuves
de vérification des connaissances dans
le cadre de la procédure d'autorisation
d'exercice cette situation risque en de
fragiliser la continuité de
fonctionnement de certains
établissements de santé il était
nécessaire de prendre la mesure
c'est pourquoi l'article 51 du projet de
loi de finances de la sécurité sociale
pour 2012 dont les dispositions sont
reprises dans la proposition de loi de
monsieur jean pierre door prévoyait de
permettre à ces praticiens sous réserve
qu'il remplisse certaines conditions de
poursuivre leurs fonctions au sein des
établissements de santé jusqu'au 31
décembre 2014
cette date a été repoussée au 31
décembre 2016 par les députés avec le
soutien du gouvernement pour permettre à
l'ensemble des praticiens de se
présenter aux épreuves à trois reprises
par ailleurs
la proposition de loi prévoit d'aménager
la procédure d'autorisation d'exercice
réservé à ces praticiens par
l'institution d'une nouvelle épreuve de
vérification des connaissances au
contenu moins académique laissant
davantage de place à l'évaluation des
compétences cliniques
ces modalités seront précisées par
décret cette évaluation sera après avis
du jury suivi ou non d'une année
probatoire de fonctions exercées en
établissement de santé afin de permettre
à la commission d'autorisation
d'exercice compétentes d'apprécier leur
cursus et leur aptitude à la prise en
charge des patients un décret précisera
les fonctions permettant d'être
éligibles au dispositif aménager des
preuves de vérification des
connaissances
enfin je souhaite préciser que même si
la date du 31 décembre 2011 ne
concernait que les médecins et les
chirurgiens dentistes dans un souci de
cohérence
le gouvernement a souhaité que
l'ensemble des professions médicales et
les pharmaciens puissent bénéficier de
la mesure proposée pour terminer je
souhaite appeler votre attention sur le
fait que le caractère consensuel de la
disposition que je vais que j'évoquais
au début de les propos conduit le
gouvernement à soutenir la proposition
de loi de ces empires d'or je ne doute
pas que vos débats seront de grande
qualité et je vous remercie de
l'attention que voudrait bien apporter à
cette proposition de loi je vous
remercie
merci madame le ministre dans la
discussion générale la parole est à me
dit monsieur yves daudigny rapporteur de
la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues les professionnels
diplômés hors de l'union européenne
occupe de longue date une place
essentielle entre système de santé il
assume le fonctionnement quotidien de
nombre de services hospitaliers
notamment dans les zones sous dotées en
praticien que ce soit dans de petites et
moyennes agglomérations ou en banlieue
certes il existe une procédure de
reconnaissance des diplômes longue et
complexe qui prend la forme d'un
concours et dont le nombre de places est
limité
mais ceux qui ne s'y soumettent pas ou
qui échoue se retrouve placé dans la
situation délicate où il ne dispose pas
d'une autorisation d'exercice pleine et
entière
leurs compétences sont alors limitées et
il exerce sous la responsabilité d'un
titulaire
leur statut reste précaire et leurs
conditions de rémunération sont souvent
indécentes par rapport à leurs collègues
diplômés en france et à leurs
responsabilités effectives
sachant qu'ils assurent de nombreuses
heures de garde et ont la confiance de
leurs chefs de service
ceci étant cette dépendance n'est en
fait que théorique et très éloignés de
la pratique car dans les faits ils
assument pleinement leur rôle de
soignant l'objet l'objet de la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui est de trouver une solution
pérenne à une question ancienne et est
aussi au fond de reconnaître le travail
que ces professionnels accomplis ce tous
les jours au service des patients
son dispositif est à double effet
immédiat et de plus long terme
elle permet tout d'abord aux médecins et
chirurgiens dentistes recrutés sur
diplôme étranger avant le 3 ou 2010 dans
un hôpital ou dans un établissement
privé à but lucratif à but non lucratif
de continuer d'exercer jusqu'au 31
décembre 2016 alors que cette faculté
cette étape où 31 décembre dernier
ensuite durant cette période de cinq ans
ceux qui auront travaillé durant trois
années pourront se présenter à une
épreuve de vérification des
connaissances
aujourd'hui les épreuves repose sur un
contrôle à la fois théorique et pratique
ce qui peut être rédhibitoire pour des
patriciens dix praticiens pardon
diplômés qui exerce depuis de nombreuses
années mais qui consacre la majeure
partie de leur temps à assurer des
gardes
désormais cette épreuve reposera
uniquement sur le contrôle des
compétences de l'expérience
professionnelle du cursus du candidat sa
spearhead une procédure de validation
des acquis de l'expérience me semble
tout à fait positif des épreuves seront
ainsi organisées chaque année jusqu'en
ceux qui auront satisfait à cette
épreuve de vérification des
connaissances devront ensuite exercé
durant une année probatoire avant de
présenter leur dossier devant une
commission où siègent le repère les
fonctions exercées auparavant pour entre
est prise en compte pour valider cette
année de stage après avis de cette
commission le ministre en charge de la
santé pourra autoriser l'exercice plein
et entier de sa profession ou candidats
cette nouvelle procédure est déclinée
pour les pharmaciens et les sages-femmes
et adaptée aux spécificités de leur
statut mes chers collègues vous le savez
il est urgent d'adopter cette
proposition de loi
car le régime dérogatoire précédent mis
en place dans la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2007 s'est clos
ou 31 ou 31 décembre dernier
théoriquement les professionnels qui
exercice sous ce régime ne devrait plus
pouvoir le faire et la période de vide
juridique doit être la plus courte
possible
les ministres ont certes signé une
instruction destiné aux agences
régionales de santé et aux
établissements mais sa portée juridique
est fragile il faut reconnaître ici que
le gouvernement a tardé à proposer une
mesure tendant à assurer la continuité
du service public en l'inscrivant au
dernier moment dans la loi de
financement
la sécurité sociale pour 2012 votée en
novembre dernier
on peut aussi s'étonner de la décision
du conseil constitutionnel d'invalider
cette mesure en considérant qu'elle
n'entrait pas dans le champ d'une loi de
financement décision inattendue
puisqu'il avait accepté lors de la
précédente réforme qui elle-même
figurait dans la loi de financement pour
2007 saisie à l'épaule de ce texte le
conseil constitutionnel n'avait rien
trouvé à y redire
nous ne pouvons que prendre acte bien
sûr de l'évolution de la jurisprudence
du conseil en raison de l'urgence mon
collègue député rapporteur pour
l'assemblée nationale et moi-même nous
sommes concertés en amont nous sommes
ensemble convenu que la date de 2016
était préférable à celle de 2014
initialement retenue en effet bien que
simplifier les procédures de meuron
longue et ce délai supplémentaire de
deux ans permettra de prendre en compte
la situation des candidats qui exercent
à temps partiel en commission des
affaires sociales beaucoup d'entre vous
se sont interrogés cette énième réforme
suffira-t-elle
ne devrions nous pas y revenir en 2016
peut-être mais un élément a changé en
2010 auparavant les praticiens à diplôme
hors union européenne pouvaient
s'inscrire aisément en faculté pour
compléter leur formation par une
spécialisation en france c'est par ce
biais que les établissements de santé et
recruter et nombre de professionnels
enchaîné les spécialisations pour
pouvoir ont fait assumer leurs fonctions
à l'hôpital depuis le 3 août 2010 cela
n'est plus possible
l'université de strasbourg centralise la
procédure d'inscription en
spécialisation pour ses diplômés et des
établissements ne peuvent donc vraiment
plus dé recruter directement
madame la ministre il est encore un peu
tôt pour dresser un bilan de cette
nouvelle procédure
mais pouvez vous tout de même nous en
présenter les premiers
résultat je les dis l'adoption de ce
texte est nécessaire et urgente pour
autant je m'interroge sur le fait qu'il
puisse résoudre les problèmes aigus que
connaît l'hôpital en france pour
recruter pour recruter des
professionnels médicaux auxiliaires et
paramédicaux notamment dans certaines
zones
ce sont d'ailleurs souvent ces mêmes
territoires qui rencontrent des
difficultés d'accès aux soins
on ce qui concerne la médecine de ville
j'imagine que le gouvernement espère que
l'augmentation du numerus clausus
permettra de pourvoir les postes vacants
permettez moi d'en douter nous aurons
dans les prochains mois un débat sur le
niveau adéquat du numerus clausus le
gouvernement vient de le relever très
légèrement la cour des comptes estime
plutôt qui sera nécessaire à moyen terme
le bc je crois surtout qu'il faut avoir
une perspective pluriannuel fiable et
stable
mais ce n'est pas notre débat de ce jour
la question des diplômés hors de l'union
européenne se pose depuis le début de
l'année 70 des années 70 c'est à dire on
va depuis 40 ans je crois donc qu'elle
n'est pas fondamentalement lié au nombre
du médecin de médecins que nous formons
chaque année dans nos universités
puisque à l'époque le numerus clausus
était d'un niveau élevé
elle est à mon sens davantage lié à
l'attractivité des métiers de l'hôpital
et là la situation est inquiétante
certes le nombre de praticiens
hospitaliers a beaucoup progressé ces
dernières années à la fois pour
accompagner l'aménagement et la
réduction du temps de travail mais aussi
pour transformer des postes de
contractuels en emplois de titulaires
pour autant d'après les chiffres dont je
dispose les vacances de postes
statutaires sont très nombreuses 22
pour cent des postes à temps plein et 37
% de ceux à temps partiel ne sont pas
pourvus par un titulaire ou par un
stagiaire en outre on ne peut plus
réfléchir de manière globale mais plutôt
par territoire et spécialités je le
répète mais c'est le coeur du problème
certains de nos territoires sont en
sous-effectif chronique de médecins ou
d'auxiliaires médicaux ceux qui
participent de l'augmentation des
comportements de renoncement aux soins
que toutes les études corrobore en ce
qui concerne l'hôpital par exemple le
tiers des postes à temps plein et
vacances a clairement en basse normandie
ou en picardie
les difficultés sont par ailleurs très
variable selon les spécialités
les spécialités à l'hôpital plus du
tiers des postes sont vacants
statutairement en oncologie ou en
radiologie
comment admettre dans certains
départements qu'un patient attendre six
mois pour avoir rendez-vous
jeanne ophtalmologiste c'est là aussi
inacceptable en travaillant sur ce texte
beaucoup plus longuement que je le
pensais au début d'ailleurs malgré les
délais contraints qui nous ont été
imposées j'ai été frappé par la
complexité des cadres d'emplois après
l'internât les médecins qui souhaitent
continuer d'exercer à l'hôpital peuvent
être recrutés sur tant de position
statutaire qu'il est très difficile de
s'y retrouver
chef de clinique attaché praticiens
assistant chacun de ces postes ayant été
déclinée pour les diplômes hors de
l'union européenne
ne pourrions nous pas simplifier ce
paysage administratif qui ne peut que
favoriser la cooptation et la précarité
pas moins de six rapports études et
enquêtes ont été adressées au
gouvernement
entre 2008 et 2011 sur l'exercice
médical à l'hôpital
le constat est donc connu pour attirer
les jeunes praticiens et fidéliser ceux
qui sont déjà engagés dans le service
public
il faut notamment valoriser et
accompagner les carrières et les
parcours trop erratique aujourd'hui
améliorer les conditions de travail
concentré le temps disponible sur l'acte
médical faire vivre les équipes et mieux
recourir à la pluridisciplinarité
quelle ne fut donc pas ma surprise de
lire hier soir une dépêche annonçant la
signature par monsieur le ministre en
charge du travail de l'emploi et de la
santé d'un accord cadre relatif à
l'exercice médical à l'hôpital
ma réaction ce rêve de dire plus tôt
tout ça pour ça
la plupart des annonces faites sont en
fait renvoyer à un groupe de travail
dote son subordonné à des concertations
multiples et variées on envisage par
exemple l'ouverture d'une négociation
statutaire débutant au 1er semestre 2012
on ne peut guère faire plus dilatoire à
quelques semaines d'échéances
électorales majeures
les seuls points concrets décidé depuis
juillet 2011
mais encore envoyé à d'ultérieures
textes d'application concerne une
amélioration des régimes complémentaires
et surcomplémentaire de retraite donc
derrière ces tombes ont enrobé vous me
permettez cette formulation le coeur de
cet accord consiste en réalité à tenter
de s'occuper enfin de la question
lancinante des comptes épargne temps
mais les premières réactions syndicales
sont pour le moins mitigés et me laisse
penser que rien n'est réglé
madame la ministre pourriez vous nous
donner des informations à donc à la
représentation nationale sur cette
question
enfin je suis quelque peu perplexe sur
la création d'une nouvelle strate
administrative
les équipes médicales en plus des
services épaules autant je défend
l'existence des kits de soin
pluridisciplinaire autant je ne vois pas
bien comment ce qui est prévu dans
l'accord pourra réellement fonctionné
dans l' architecture déjà très complexe
de l'hôpital ce que nous avions dénoncé
durant l'examen de la loi
hpst l'hôpital est ouvert tous les jours
toute l'année 24 heures sur 24
il est souvent un repère un ancrage dans
la ville et il est nécessairement au
coeur du système de soins l'
architecture d'ensemble de la prise en
charge des patients doit bien sûr
s'adapter aux évolutions de la société
et des techniques thérapeutiques
notamment le développement de
l'ambulatoire et la volonté de rester à
domicile
il est impératif que notre société
puisse appuyer sur un système de santé
efficace et solidaire cette solidarité
est aujourd'hui en danger d'une part au
détriment de patients qui ne dispose
plus de moyens de financer ce qui leur
reste à charge
d'autre part aux dépens de ceux qui se
heurte à l'absence de professionnels sur
le territoire où ils vivent
cette question sera l'un des enjeux de
la campagne présidentielle qui a débuté
et dépasse j'en suis conscient
l'objet de la présente proposition de
loi mais je n'aurais pas estimé juste de
la passer sous silence au moment de ce
débat monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues notre
commission a adopté le texte qui nous
est soumis à l'unanimité et sans
modification en raison de l'urgence à
sécuriser le fonctionnement quotidien de
nos hôpitaux
cet objectif est éminemment prioritaires
et j'appelle chacune et chacun d'entre
nous à suivre la commission dans cette
démarche
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole et à
madame aline archimbaud
monsieur le président madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues comme le
rapporteur yves daudigny vous l'a
démontré l'adoption de cette proposition
de loi par le sénat est aujourd'hui
indispensable
elle est indispensable car le 15
décembre dernier en effet le conseil
constitutionnel a censuré l'article de
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2012 qui prolongeait du 31
décembre 2011 au 31 décembre 2014
autorisation pour les médecins diplômés
à l'étranger d'exercer en france leur
laissant ainsi le temps de passer un
examen d'équivalence
depuis certains d'entre eux ont commencé
à recevoir des lettres de reconduite à
la frontière émanant du préfet et il ya
donc aujourd'hui bel et bien urgence à
adopter cette proposition de loi
mais si l'adoption de cette proposition
de loi est indispensable c'est surtout
parce que les médecins chirurgiens
dentistes pharmaciens et sages femmes
titulaires d'un diplôme obtenu dans un
état non membre de l'union européenne
sont eux-mêmes indispensable à notre
système de soins je vous rappelle en
effet et yves daudigny a cité également
un certain nombre de cas que si nous
sommes aujourd'hui amenés à adopter
cette proposition de loi en urgence
c'est parce que les hôpitaux publics
jongle tant bien que mal avec le droit
depuis les années 70 pour assurer le
fonctionnement de leurs services et
notamment des gardes à l'hôpital
d'argentan dans l'orne sur trente deux
spécialistes
douze sont titulaires d'un diplôme
obtenu à l'étranger au centre
psychothérapique d'alençon toujours dans
l'orne
plus d'un tiers des praticiens sont
menacés je ne vais pas passer en revue
tous les départements mais sachez que
l'orne est loin d'être une exception en
la matière vous serez donc d'accord avec
moi mes chers collègues nous ne pouvons
faire aujourd'hui l'économie d'une telle
loi
toutefois c'est impérieuse nécessité
légiférer en urgence ne nous empêche pas
d'interroger le dispositif et de et de
réfléchir à la situation des personnes
concernées
tout d'abord l'adoption à la de cette
mesure de court terme ne nous épargnera
pas la nécessité de poser réellement et
dans les délais les plus brefs
le problème de la démographie médicale
qui se pose de manière de plus en plus
frag plat grant hill d'houdini largement
développée car on ne pourra pas toujours
se servir comme d'une béquille de cette
variable d'ajustement que constituent
les professionnels de santé formés à
l'étranger puisque c'est malheureusement
ainsi qu'ils sont traités se servir de
ces personnes le mot est dure mais il
reflète bel et bien la réalité la
réalité de personnel qui certes ont un
diplôme obtenu à l'étranger mais qui ne
sont pas pour autant moins compétents la
réalité de personnel employé avec un
statut extrêmement précaire et qui
peuvent du jour au lendemain être mis à
la porte sur n'estime n'avoir plus
besoin d'eux la réalité de personnel qui
travaille sans compter et enchaîne les
gardes de nuit
les gars de la nuit et le week end sans
aucune perspective la réalité de
personnel qui donnent toute leur énergie
leur motivation pour assurer la
continuité des soins l'accès à la santé
de nos concitoyens mais qui sont souvent
payés au smic soit trois voire quatre
fois moins que leurs collègues
détenteur d'un diplôme français alors
que leurs missions et leurs compétences
dans les faits sont les mêmes alors me
direz vous il existe une porte de sortie
pour ces personnes une procédure en
trois étapes
que vous a décrite mon collègue
rapporteur leur permet d'être autorisés
à exercer en france
cependant le concours en question est
exagérément sélectif
dix postes pour 200 candidats en
médecine générale 5 places pour 300
médecins gynécologues inscrits et aucun
poste ouvert en anesthésie réanimation
depuis trois ans inutile de vous dire
que la réussite à ce concours est donc
quasi impossible pour les professionnels
de santé concernés
surtout que le rythme de travail qui est
le leur leur laisse peu de temps et de
sérénité pour réviser
par ailleurs il leur faut pour pouvoir
passer cette épreuve justifier d'une
période d'exercice suffisamment longue
trois ans pour les médecins par exemple
or beaucoup de diplômés étrangers ne
trouvons pas de postes médicaux à leur
arrivée en france exerce en fait sur des
postes infirmiers ou exercent des
fonctions d'enseignement ou de recherche
par exemple leur situation ne leur
permet donc pas de se soumettre aux
concours en question seconde injustice
il existe deux dérogations pour les
réfugiés et les apatrides et pour les
personnes en poste avant le 10 juin 2004
pour lesquels un examen auquel il leur
suffit d'obtenir la moyenne remplace la
procédure extrêmement sélective décrite
ci dessus pour les personnes bénéficiant
de dérogations une solution existe donc
mais quelle injustice pour les autres
ceux qui sont arrivés en france après
2004 depuis des années et parfois depuis
2005 exact donc dans le système français
avec dévouement maîtrise parfaitement
notre langue ont fondé une famille se
sont intégrés souvent ils ont continué à
se former dans universités françaises
obtenant pour beaucoup d'entre eux des
diplômes universitaires de troisième
cycle et des capacités en médecine
la situation actuelle est donc vécue par
beaucoup comme une forte injustice
doublée d'une discrimination entre
médecins titulaires du diplôme
équivalent c'est donc un assouplissement
de la procédure d'autorisation
d'exercice que je vous demande
solennellement aujourd'hui madame la
ministre
car je sais que le décret d'application
prévues par le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui pourrait permettre à de
nombreuses personnes d'exercer leurs
missions de soins dans des conditions
plus sereines
en conclusion mes chers collègues vous
l'aurez compris le groupe écologiste
appelle bien sûr a voté pour cette
proposition de loi en adopter une
version conforme à celle que vient
d'adopter l'assemblée nationale pour
éviter de perdre encore du temps mais
nous espérons également que le
gouvernement aura entendu nos remarques
sort allait prendre en compte pour plus
d'équité plus de justice et pour que les
détenteurs de diplômes étrangers que je
salue aujourd'hui pour leur dévouement
leur professionnalisme leur
détermination puisse exercer sereinement
leur métier et leur vocation
je vous remercie merci ma chère collègue
la parole est à monsieur alain millions
monsieur le président dans la ministre
madame la présidente
la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur rapporteur général mes chers
collègues dans sa décision du 15
décembre 2011 le conseil constitutionnel
a censuré l'article 51 de la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale pour
considérant qu'il constitue est un
cavalier sociale or cet article encadrer
les conditions d'exercice de certains
professionnels de santé titulaire d'un
diplôme obtenu hors de l'union
européenne
si aucune disposition législative
intervient rapidement près de 4000
professionnels de santé vont devoir
cesser leurs activités car ils se
trouvent dans une situation d'illégalité
que les chefs de service ne pourront
plus couvrir longtemps sans risquer de
voir engager des actions en
responsabilité
ainsi la proposition de loi que nous
examinons vise à répondre à une double
nécessité d'une part de nature
conjoncturelle aux termes de l'article
83 de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2007
les professionnels de santé titulaire
d'un diplôme obtenu hors de l'union
européenne n'était habilité à poursuivre
leur activité sous des statuts
d'exercice restreint que jusqu'au 31
décembre 2011 dans le cadre d'une
procédure dérogatoire d'autorisation la
censure du conseil constitutionnel ayant
empêché la mise en oeuvre du dispositif
transitoire initialement prévu ces
professionnels de santé sont maintenus
lors un statut pour le moins précaire
nous sommes donc face à un vide
juridique vous êtes face à un vide
juridique
d'autre part il s'agit d'une nécessité
de nature structurelle
en effet les établissements de santé ont
besoin de recourir à des professionnels
pour pallier au manque d'attractivité de
l'hôpital public et il serait
irresponsable de laisser partir un
personnel formé qui a su montrer ses
compétences et son investissement auprès
des patients pour ces raisons
le gouvernement lors de l'examen du
plfss 2012 avait proposé devant
l'assemblée nationale un amendement qui
visait d'une part à proroger le
dispositif transitoire d'autorisation
d'exercer jusqu'au 31 décembre 2014
d'autre part à introduire de nouvelles
épreuves de vérification des
connaissances pour les médecins
étrangers diplômés hors de l'union
européenne dans cette logique le groupe
ump du sénat
en proposant un amendement était allé
plus loin et avait ainsi élargi et
assouplit le dispositif puisque d'une
part il permettait à l'ensemble des
sages-femmes recruter jusqu'à date de
publication des rois le financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2012 d'entrer
dans le champ de ce nouveau dispositif
d'autre part il permettait d'alléger la
contrainte selon laquelle les lauréats
de l'épreuve d'aptitude devait effectuer
une période probatoire
or compte tenu des durées de service de
certains candidats cet amendement
offrait à la commission l'autorisation
d'exercice compétentes la possibilité de
prendre en compte les fonctions exercées
afin qu'elle vaille année rogatoire
d'ailleurs nous pouvons rappeler pour
nous en féliciter que cet amendement
avait été adopté dans notre hémicycle à
l'unanimité témoignant ainsi d'un large
consensus
la proposition de loi soumise à notre
examen aujourd'hui vise à reprendre ce
dispositif introduit en première lecture
dans le plfss pour 2012
elle comporte également un second
article afin de tenir compte du vide
juridique dans lequel nous nous trouvons
actuellement en prévoyant d'une
application des dispositions de manière
rétroactive au 1er janvier 2012
si la sécurité juridique le pouce
d'ordinaire à ne pas demander la
rétroactivité des textes votés sept
situations particulières le justifient
afin de régulariser a posteriori la
période d'exercice des praticiens
concernés comprise entre le 1er janvier
2012 et la date d'entrée en vigueur de
la présente proposition de loi cette
proposition de loi permettant ainsi de
prolonger pour les praticiens le système
dérogatoire qui consiste à ne pas être
soumis à un concours mais à un examen
puisque les lauréats aux épreuves de
vérification connaissance ne se verront
pas opposer la limitation du nombre de
postes ouverts ce dispositif bénéficiera
aux médecins ou chirurgiens-dentistes
aux sages femmes et aux pharmaciens en
outre comme je voulais préciser le texte
introduit une nouvelle épreuve de
connaissances distincte de la procédure
de droit commun et il réduit la période
probatoire à un an durée pendant
laquelle les praticiens exerceront soit
des statuts d 1,6 restreint les est
nécessaire que le centre national de
gestion donne une information précise
aux pattes aux praticiens pour qu'ils
aient accès à cette procédure et leur
permettent ainsi de clarifier leur
situation d'un ministre
pouvez-vous nous assurer que cette
formation sera bien réalisé
en outre je souhaite vous alerter madame
la ministre sur le fait que l'épreuve
d'évaluation des acquis douane est doit
être bien adapté à la spécialisation du
médecin il serait paradoxal de faire
passer des épreuves théoriques à des
messins qui exerce depuis de nombreuses
années et dont la qualité du travail
reconnu néanmoins la date butoir
repoussait de deux ans par les députés
est portée au 31 décembre 2016
me paraît plus réaliste cela devrait
diminuer au plus vite le nombre de
professionnels qui ne bénéficient plus
de la paix ni tu d'exercice dans les
établissements de santé
même si la procédure d'autorisation
d'exercice a permis de régulariser
régulariser une majorité de mme et m
étrangers exerçant dans des hôpitaux il
en demeure encore qui n'ont pu améliorer
leur situation soit parce qu'ils ont été
joués examen soit parce qu'ils ne sont
pas ne se sont pas présentés aux
épreuves
or nous ne pouvons plus décemment les
accusés de dilettantisme leur journée
extrêmement chargé ne leur permettent
pas de préparer leur concours dans de
bonnes conditions et dans certains cas
les empêche même de se rendre aux
épaules et souvent par crainte d'échouer
faute de préparation suffisante
il n'a aussi présentés pourtant ces
médecins représenter c'est déjà été dit
dans certaines zones géographiques
juste à 30% du personnel des
établissements de santé
la prolongation du dispositif
transitoire jusqu'en 2016 que prévoit
cette proposition de loi donne donc une
bouffée d'oxygène aux hôpitaux en
laissant cinq années supplémentaires
pour parachever le processus de
régularisation de ces professionnels de
santé avant de conclure madame la
ministre je souhaite aussi contrairement
aux intervenants précédents salué la
détermination du gouvernement à trouver
une solution au problème de non paiement
des rtt à l'hôpital en effet depuis la
loi de 2002 sur les 35 heures à
l'hôpital
la plupart des médecins hospitaliers
n'ont pu prendre toute leur journée de
congé supplémentaires dues au titre de
la réduction du temps de travail et je
suis convaincu que cette loi de 2002 a
contribué à déstabiliser l'hôpital de
nous félicitons donc de l'accord trouvé
avec les praticiens hospitaliers
le groupe ump votera naturellement cet
ex temps merci mon cher collègue dans la
suite discussions général la parole
était madame nathalie goulet
oui monsieur le président le ministre
mes chers collègues l'orne est bien
représentée et notre collègue de tout à
l'heure du groupe écologiste a
longuement parlé de ce département et je
l'en remercie bien vivement parce que
c'est vrai que nous sommes dans une
situation difficile dont je fais
intervenir très brièvement
il s'agit d'une disposition que nous
avions adopté dans le plfss et que
j'avais soutenu j'étais d'ailleurs
intervenu sur l'article ce qui explique
ma mon intervention très brève encore
une fois même le ministre dans la
discussion générale pour vous dire à
quel point cette mesure est évidemment
attendu dieu merci les médecins
étrangers hors union européenne qui
exercent dans nos hôpitaux
spécifiquement dans les zones rurales ou
dans les autres hôpitaux d'ailleurs ne
suivent pas les travaux du conseil
constitutionnel et non pas forcément
tous eu connaissance de ce que cette
disposition qu'ils attendaient et qui
les avaient temps soulagé a été a été
censurée par le conseil constitutionnel
donc finalement soyons discret ce soir
sur notre pardon oui le savent
enfin disons disons que disons que c'est
peut-être pas la peine d'en faire une
trop grande publicité salle et ça les
inquiète ray davantage alors qu'ils
avaient ils avaient été totalement
rassurés on a la solution oui oui non
mais justement justement donc donc si
vous les mois comme le disait notre
collègue tout à l'heure nous sommes dans
une situation où la démographie médicale
est évidemment très douloureuse vous
savez que notre ami commun pierre-jean
lancry travail et gère remarquablement
la région basse normandie en ce qui
concerne la rs mais il n'en demeure pas
moins vrai que les problèmes de
démographie médicale demeure le compte
qui a été donnée par notre collègue
d'après les d'après les chiffres qu'elle
a trouvées sont pas tout à fait exacts
mais il est vrai qu'à cinq médecins
étrangers hors union européenne à flers
qui en a neuf argentan qui en a aussi à
alençon et que leur situation avait
vraiment ému non seulement les
populations mais aussi les élus et
et c'est bien normal donc aujourd'hui
vous nous apporter la solution on ne
peut évidemment que se satisfaire de
cette de cette disposition en ce qui
concerne les autres dispositions de
toutes façons de que nous pourrions
prendre concernant la démographie
médicale vous savez très bien que dans
le projet hôpital patients santé
territoires nous avions voté des
dispositions de contraintes pour faire
venir des médecins alors milieu rural je
vois que vous seriez mais si vous voulez
on a assez peu de temps pour les loisirs
est en fait c'est l'occasion de vous
rappeler que nous sommes un certain
nombre dans cet hémicycle a prôné des
mesures de contrainte pour faire venir
les médecins en zone rurale en dehors
des problèmes d'attractivité comme vous
le savez très bien
c'est une espèce de rengaine mais
finalement on ne s'en lasse pas c'est
l'état qui paye les études des médecins
c'est la sécurité sociale absolument
la sécurité sociale qui rembourse mais
nous avons des divergences tout à fait
honorable de ce oui à condition qu'ils
aient des médecins certains élus de
l'orne certains élus de leur père y en a
d'autres cellules d'autres élus oui il
ya aussi des pôles de santé n'y a pas de
médecin dedans merci le seul président
j'ai donc la parole seul et donc à
partir du moment où certains élus de
l'ordre préfère ceux ci d'autres élus de
l'homme préfère cela mais je sais que
dans cet hémicycle et notamment de ce
côté là on me comprendra enfin et donc
la gaule la gaule à gauche au secours
oui la gauche secours fait que j'ai fait
60% des voix aux élections sénatoriales
ce qui n'est pas si mal
en conséquence en conséquence de quoi je
continue à penser que des mesures de
contrainte pour faire venir les médecins
en zone rurale et en zones urbaines
défavorisées sont des mesures que nous
finirons par prendre et qui aideront
évidemment les pôles de santé
l'attractivité tout ce que peut mettre
en place les oui tout ce que peut mettre
en place les conseils généraux et les
conseils régionaux qui payent qui paye
quand même une grande partie puisque
tous tous ces maisons toutes ces mesures
sont toutes ces mesures de soutien
mesuré sont quand même coordonnées
maintenant grâce notamment à l agence
régionale de santé
tout ça tout ça tout ça contribue
mais il n'empêche que vous avez
incertaine la maison de la santé seul le
pôle de santé seules ne règle pas le
problème si les médecins ne sont pas
d'accord pour les animer vous pouvez
avoir des coquilles vides et ça ne
réglera pas nos problèmes
donc même le ministre je suis très
heureuse de vous voir à ce banc ce soir
je suis très heureux de vous dire que
les engagements pris par le ministre
était important il nous a écrit à tous
les deux
il nous a écrit à tous les deux nous
avons reçu la même lettre c'était
formidable mais voilà cette disposition
c'est non pas du tout cette disposition
dépend du parlement et donc c'est une
très bonne chose aujourd'hui que nous
puissions régler ce problème qui est un
problème important il faudra revoir sa
disposition évidemment en 2014 et je ne
doute pas que d'ici là nous pourrons
examiner un texte qui pourra en tout les
cas améliorer la situation de nos
départements ruraux et de nos zones
urbaines sensibles en contraignant un
tout petit peu les médecins parce que
vous savez comme moi que nous n'avons
jamais formé autant de médecins en
france qu'il n'y a jamais eu autant de
médecins en france qu'ils sont
extrêmement mal répartie que les
territoires ruraux ne sont pas des
français de seconde zone qui a aucune
espèce de raison que nous payons trois
fois une fois avec le budget une fois eu
de la sécurité sociale et j'ajoute une
troisième fois avec le collectivités
territoriales pour être soigné tout ça
n'est pas normal et je pense qu'il est
grand temps que nous puis nous prenions
des mesures qu'ils souhaitent appliquer
je vous remercie
merci mes chers collègues la parole est
un monsieur gilbert barbier
monsieur le président ce qu'interdit
d'amis chers collègues je ne reviendrai
pas sur les circonstances qui nous amène
à discuter cette proposition de loi
préférant insister plus tôt sur son
enjeu sanitaire immédiat à l'heure où
nous parlons près de 4000 praticiens
dans nos hôpitaux nous hanter aurait
plus le droit d'exercer depuis le 31
décembre 2011
ce gie de praticiens titulaire d'un
diplôme hors union européenne comme ça a
été soulignée qui n'ont pas satisfait
les épreuves de vérification des
connaissances de la procédure
d'autorisation d'exercice
cette procédure qui a été mise en place
dans la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale en 2007
cette situation soulève deux problèmes
tout d'abord celui de la continuité des
soins dans un certain nombre
d'établissements publics ou privés
d'intérêt collectif qui dépendent en
partie de ces praticiens
ensuite est surtout celui de leur
couverture assurantielle en
responsabilité civile
imaginons à quelles difficultés
s'exposerait les praticiens les
établissements qui les emploient c'est
un incident médical survenait un
problème urgent réponse urgente cette
proposition de loi vise en effet à
prolonger jusqu'au 31 décembre 2016
dispositif transitoire l'autorisation
d'exercice restreint pour bénéficier nos
bénéficier les paluds est à prévoir une
nouvelle époque vérification des
connaissances ou les modalités seront
fixées par décret une fois de plus on
aurait souhaité connaître avant de voter
le contenu exact ou tout du moins les
orientations de ce décret peut-être
madame le ministre
en avez vous une idée malgré cela est
sans doute la meilleure solution si on
se concentre sur l'enjeu immédiat qui
est de garantir la permanence des soins
la grande majorité des praticiens à
diplôme étranger occupent des postes
indispensables au fonctionnement des
établissements ça a été bien sûr bien
souligner aux urgences en réanimation en
médecine
où ils rendent des services importants
pour des rémunérations inférieures à
celles du titulaire
cette distorsion salariale n'est pas son
nouveau interpellé sur ce retard à la
régularisation des diplômes s'agit-il
d'une manoeuvre peut être orientée dans
ce sens
par ailleurs beaucoup de ces médecins
sont aujourd'hui français ayant acquis
la nationalité française depuis leur
arrivée notamment par le mariage et ont
des enfants eux aussi français enfin
pour connaître le nombre de ces
praticiens être intervenu en faveur de
certains je sais qu'ils sont pour la
plupart d'entre eux pas tous cependant
dévoués et compétents
il faut le reconnaître et le valider par
des épreuves adaptées ne pas faire ne
pas le faire serait injuste qui
aggraverait des difficultés d'un certain
nombre d'établissements confrontés à des
vacances de postes
ceci étant je ne vous cache pas
certaines interrogations pourquoi alors
que ces praticiens ont acquis très
souvent une expérience et une compétence
réelle ont-ils pas passer les épreuves
de vérification des connaissances avant
la date fatidique
comment comprendre aussi que d'un côté
on a privé d'études médicales un certain
nombre d'étudiants français par un
numerus clausus trop contraint et que
dans l'autre côté perdure une procédure
dérogatoire pour les praticiens
étrangers
qu'on ne se méprenne pas je ne me pose
nullement un exercice de la médecine
dans notre pays par des praticiens
étrangers citant que leurs compétences
sont validés je note au passage ne
serait pas là si la vérification des
connaissances avait lieu avant la prise
de fonction même pour les praticiens
exerçant sur un statut restreint une
fois leurs compétences établies
devraient pouvoir prétendre un statut
professionnel et salarial égal à ceux de
leurs homologues à diplôme français mais
je crois madame le ministre nous
devrions réfléchir à l'adaptation de
notre système de formation aux enjeux
sanitaires de notre pays
alors que près de 10000 postes ne sont
pas pourvus par des praticiens titulaire
est il raisonnable d'imposer une
solution sélection si drastiques à la
fin de la première année ça a été évoqué
par un certain nombre de facteurs
précédents - d'attractivité de certains
postes hospitaliers des affections de la
peau la médecine générale est inégale
répartition sur le territoire
on vient d'en parler longuement la
situation est préoccupante
certes des mesures ont été prises pour
faire face à cette situation
spécialité de médecine générale
multiplication des maisons
pluridisciplinaires de santé
régionalisation du numerus clausus
contrat d'engagement de service public
mais je ne suis pas convaincu que cela
soit suffisant
le ministère de la santé réfléchit à des
mesures plus efficaces
peut-être salariale dans cette période
de régularisation de la rtt
quoi qu'il en soit le secteur de la
santé au genre a aujourd'hui besoin de
ces 4000 praticiens à diplôme étranger
la proposition de loi apporte une
réponse à leurs besoins légitimes de
reconnaissance et fixe les conditions
qui garantissent la compétence attendu
et nécessaire à la qualité des soins
c'est pourquoi nous la voterons espérant
qu'à l'échéance de 2016
le problème soit réglé et que nous
puissions trouver de nouvelles solutions
autres que les mesures coercitives qui
ne changerait évidemment pas la donne
pour répondre aux besoins de nombreux
territoires qui désespère j'ajouterai
pour terminer qu'il est urgent également
de se préoccuper du sort des étudiants
étrangers diplômés dans leur pays qu'ils
exercent sur des postes para médicaux
dans les hôpitaux dans des conditions
difficilement acceptables ce cas ne sont
pas ici résolu et c'est bien regrettable
merci merci mon cher collègue dans la
suite des discussions générales la
parole et de madame dominique watrin
je
eh bien monsieur le président madame la
ministre
chers collègues je voudrais d'abord tout
d'abord rendre hommage à tous ces
praticiens qui exercent en france et qui
ont obtenu leur diplôme dans un état non
membre de l'union européenne c'est en
partie grâce à leur travail cela déjà
été soulignée un travail exercé dans des
conditions souvent précaires que la
qualité du système de santé français est
maintenu c'est leur diplôme ont été
obtenus dans de nombreux pays beaucoup
d'entre eux sont d'ailleurs français et
ils ont effectué au moins une partie de
leur formation en france si leurs
compétences n'ont rien à envier aux
médecins diplômés de france et d'europe
les conditions d'exercice de leur métier
sont pourtant particulièrement difficile
et incertaine le recrutement de médecins
diplôme hors union européenne
théoriquement interdite depuis 1999 a
pratiquement continue à s'exercer
légalement et son statut et pour cause
ces praticiens palais une véritable
carence de l'hôpital public français lié
à l'insuffisance du nombre de praticiens
formés en france et alors inégale
répartition sur le territoire
le numerus clausus appliquée aux études
de médecine le manque d'attractivité des
carrières hospitalières sont telles que
sans ces praticiens diplômés hors union
européenne certains hôpitaux et services
serait tout simplement amené à fermer et
que l'on ne nous dise pas que la récente
augmentation de ce numéro sclos mise us
permettra même à terme de pallier ces
problèmes cela est faux il est facile de
le démontrer en réalité ces praticiens
sont indispensables à l'exercice d'un
service public de la santé de qualité
sur l'ensemble du territoire français
en effet elles sont souvent affectés
dans des zones de désertification
médicale et sont parfois seuls garants
de la maintenance d'hôpitaux publics de
proximité
ces médecins sont injustement traité
leur besoin de reconnaissance et
légitime sûrs égard au rôle qu'ils
remplissent la halde haute autorité de
lutte contre les discriminations et pour
l'égalité a d'ailleurs estimé dans un
délibéré du 27 février 2006 que ces
praticiens cantonné à l'hôpital sur des
statuts précaires sous payés empêché
d'exercer pleinement la médecine sont
victimes de discrimination c'est leur
absence de statut qui a servi à mieux
exploiter ces praticiens dont les
responsabilités sont pourtant identiques
à leurs homologues diplômés de l'union
européenne afin de remédier à cette
situation intolérable
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2007 a instauré un
processus d'autorisation d'exercice
dérogatoire à leur permet après examen
l'exercice plein de la médecine et leur
ouvre la possibilité d'occuper
officiellement les postes qui sont les
leurs depuis de nombreuses années
reconnaissant la valeur probante de
leurs pratiques professionnelles et
l'injustice de leur situation la loi
leur a donné jusqu'au 31 janvier 2011
pour régulariser leurs pratiques
au-delà de cette date leur droit
d'exercer dans les établissements de
santé publique a pris fin quand ils
n'ont pas satisfait aux épreuves de
vérification des connaissances ce
processus est donc arrivé à son terme et
force est de constater qu'il n'a pas
suffi on peut estimer aujourd'hui à 4000
le nombre de médecins de praticiens à
diplôme hors union européenne qui n'ont
pas pu bénéficier de l'autorisation
d'exercice qu'ils aient été remerciés ou
qu'il continue d'exercer depuis le 1er
janvier 2012
sans statut juridique ces praticiens
sont placés en grande difficulté avec
eux les hôpitaux qui continue de les
embaucher pour assurer la continuité du
service public et la permanence des
soins
mais en se plaçant dans une périlleuse
situation juridique
la situation est connue depuis longtemps
mais c'est il ya seulement quelques mois
lors de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2012 que le gouvernement a consenti
enfin déposer un amendement prolonge en
prorogeant le délai de la procédure
d'autorisation d'exercice
jusqu'à 2014 le conseil constitutionnel
ayant considéré comme un cavalier
législatif la censure et il ya donc
urgence et cette urgence nous la
déplorons si carey elle n'est lié qu'à
une incapacité ou une exigence du
gouvernement qui s'est refusé à
affronter le problème à temps nous
sommes donc contraints d'adopter
rapidement
cette proposition de loi qui reprend
l'article censuré pour ne pas pénaliser
des hommes et des femmes placées dans
l'insécurité la détresse
ce débat est précipitée j'oserais même
dire amputé
car si nous reconnaissons l'utilité de
cette proposition de loi
nous en sommes également un peu
prisonnier l'urgence de son adoption à
pêche en effet une véritable réflexion
sur le sujet je vois qu'elle est
partagée dans l'hémicycle et nous
cantonne à une loi circonstancielle
considérant exclusivement la procédure
de validation dérogatoire elle permet
d'oublier celle de droit commun et
n'affronte par la question fondamentale
des déserts médicaux
or celle ci va se poser avec plus
d'acuité que jamais puisque les médecins
formés en france resteront en nombre
insuffisant tandis que les étudiants un
diplôme hors union européenne qui
servait jusque là cela a été dit de
variable d'ajustement ne seront plus
assez nombreux
suite à la régulation introduite par
l'arrêté du 3 août 2010 en août madame
la ministre nous serons extrêmement
vigilants concernant les décrets
d'application afin qu'ils donnent les
mêmes chances à tous les diplômés hors
union européenne
nous veillerons en particulier ce qui
n'exclut pas les diplômés de médecine
qui ont accepté en france des postes
d'infirmiers ou exercent dans le secteur
paramédical l'enseignement ou encore
l'industrie pharmaceutique
d'autre part la procédure de validation
est un long parcours dont l'examen n'est
que le premier pas avant hull année
probatoire suivi de l'accord de la
commission d'autorisation d'exercice qui
peut demander si nécessaire de prolonger
la période de formation
quel accompagnement prévoyez-vous pour
permettre au maximum de ces diplômés de
réussir dans cette démarche
url eu égard leur condition
de travail difficiles par respect pour
le travail des diplômés hors union
européenne nous adopterons cette loi qui
prolonge cette procédure de validation
dérogatoire jusqu'en 2016 date qui
devrait permettre de régulariser la
totalité des praticiens cependant nous
continuerons de déplorer les conditions
de son adoption liées à la situation
regrettable dans laquelle l'incurie du
gouvernement a placé six praticiens et
surtout une absence de viser à long
terme
cette loi est utile nous la voterons
mais ce n'est qu'une rustine de plus que
nous mettrons sur notre système de santé
alors qu'il appelle au plus vite le
courage de réformes structurelles
merci mes chers collègues
la parole est à madame claudine lepage
monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'état chaque collègue nous
examinions donc ce 24 janvier une
proposition de loi qui vise à encadrer
les conditions d'exercice de certains
professionnels de santé
titulaire d'un diplôme obtenu hors de
l'union européenne
déposée le 20 décembre 2011 sur le
bureau de l'assemblée nationale est
examinée le 18 janvier 2012 par nos
collègues députés
permettez moi de saluer l'exceptionnel
efficacité du parlement mais faut-il
parler d'efficacité ou de précipitations
imposé par l'urgence de la situation
certes si nous débattons de ce texte
aujourd'hui c'est en raison de la
décision du conseil constitutionnel qui
a censuré il ya quelques semaines
l'article traitant de la question dans
la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale comme cela a déjà été mentionné
par mes collègues
le conseil constitutionnel a en effet
estimé qu'il s'agissait d'un cavalier
législatif
d'aucuns ont alors fait remarquer que le
conseil et c'était en l'occurrence
montré particulièrement scrupuleux
peut-être mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que cet épisode ne serait pas intervenu
si la majorité présidentielle avait su
anticiper c'est bien ici que réside le
problème et nous obligent à nouveau à
légiférer dans l'urgence
déjà il a fallu attendre fin 2006 pour
que soit mis en place à l'occasion du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2007 un examen
dérogatoire en parallèle la procédure
dite npa qui astreint les praticiens à
diplôme étranger alors même qu'ils
bénéficient déjà d'un poste et donc de
compétences reconnu au passage d'un
concours très sélectif il était prévu
que cette mesure dérogatoire devait
prendre fin le 31 décembre 2011
et cela dès le vote la disposition en
décembre 2006 tout juste quelques jours
avant cette date
le gouvernement a donc décidé d'intégrer
dans le pro
j'ai de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale un article prorogeant
cette mesure c'est ce que l'on peut
nommer une belle anticipation en
définitive suite à la décision du
conseil constitutionnel
ce sont quelques 4000 praticiens qui
depuis le 1er janvier dernier exerce
dans l'illégalité
or quand l'on sait que dans certaines
régions comme le nord pas de calais il
n'y a pas que l'orne en france ses
médecins à diplôme étranger qu'ils
soient français ou étrangers
représentent dans les hôpitaux
près de 50% des effectifs l'on envisage
aisément les conséquences alarmantes
d'une telle négligence la
désertification médicale est telle que
les praticiens à diplôme étranger sont
absolument essentielles pour assurer la
continuité du service public de santé en
france d'après le centre national de
gestion des praticiens hospitaliers et
des personnels de direction de la
fonction publique hospitalière
ces praticiens à diplôme obtenu hors de
l'union européenne représentaient en
2006 en 2011 entre 6700 et 7100
personnes auxquelles s'ajoutent trois
mille 300 praticiens en formation
plus précisément sur les deux cent
quatorze mille médecins actifs au 1er
janvier 2007
l'effectif total des professionnels de
santé diplômés hors de l'union
européenne s'élèverait à 17 milles et
pourtant tout indispensable qu'il soit
ces praticiens sont victimes d'une
grande précarité leur statut contractuel
renouvelables d'année en année sans
prise en compte de leurs nombreuses
années d'exercice leur salaire bien
inférieur à celui de leurs collègues à
diplôme français alors même qu'ils
exercent le même métier et en dose de
fait la même responsabilité les
conditions d'exercice de surcroît
souvent extrêmement difficiles dans des
zones désertées par leurs collègues les
gardes qui sont contraints d'accumuler à
la fois pour répondre
besoin et pour améliorer leurs salaires
et les perspectives de carrière qu'en
tout état de cause ces praticiens
n'auront jamais de même que
l'autorisation de s'installer
la proposition de loi que nous
examinions ce soir est incontestablement
nécessaire mais elle ne résout en rien
le problème de la quasi exploitation de
ces praticiens et de leur légitime
besoin de reconnaissance
je dirais même de dignité à cet égard la
haute autorité de lutte contre les
discriminations a été très clair dans sa
décision du 27 février 2006 par laquelle
elles dénonçaient une discrimination à
l'encontre de ces praticiens à diplôme
étranger trouvant sa source dans je cite
l'exploitation qui est faite de leur
absence de statut alors même que leurs
responsabilités concrètes sont titan
identique
en outre je note que le prolongement de
la période transitoire il
initialement prévue en 2014 jusqu'au 31
décembre 2016
voté par nos collègues députés est
bienvenu pour permettre aux praticiens
recruté par les établissements de santé
avant le 3 août 2010 de se présenter
dans les meilleures conditions aux
épreuves de vérification des
connaissances mais qu'en sera-t-il des
étudiants et tout récent médecins à
diplôme étranger ayant débuté leur
exercice
après 2010 à n'en pas douter le
parlement sera à nouveau saisi dans
l'urgence d'un texte en 2016 il importe
de prévoir une solution pérenne et de
faire cesser cette hypocrisie qui ne
nous honore pas si ses médecins ont les
compétences requises comme en témoigne
la place qui leur est donnée dans nos
hôpitaux et la satisfaction qu'il donne
nous devons madame la ministre cessé de
voter des textes à courte vue et donner
à ses médecins
un statut qui leur rendent leur dignité
en tout état de cause malgré les
imperfections que 7 de cette proposition
de loi
qui ne fait que régler provisoirement le
problème des praticiens à diplôme
étranger et n'envisage pas leur statut
dans sa globalité
il va sans dire que notre groupe votera
afin de ne pas accroître encore la
situation juridique et statutaire
instable et la grande précarité de ces
praticiens dont la france a tant besoin
avant de conclure je souhaite évoquer
rapidement la situation spécifique des
futurs médecins français à diplôme
étranger qui n'ont pas la possibilité de
bénéficier d'un recrutement en qualité
d'étudiant de faisant fonction d'un
terne
j'ai déjà abordé à plusieurs reprises ce
problème qui touche un grand nombre de
nos concitoyens et les place dans une
situation parfaitement injuste pour
pallier cette inégalité il suffirait
madame la secrétaire d'état
d'amender l'article 1er de l'arrêté du 8
juillet 2008 afin de permettre aux
ressortissants communautaires résidant
dans un pays extracommunautaires
d'accéder aux cycles de formation
médicale spécialisée
je vous remercie merci mes chers
collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean jacques
mirassou
si le président s'il aura pour terme
dans le ministre mes chers collègues
nous examinons effectivement ce soir
sous la pression de l'urgence un texte
essentiel pour la garantie à très court
terme de ce quinté après tout à l'heure
à juste titre la continuité des soins
dans les hôpitaux et lui reste que nous
soyons contraints d'examiner ce texte
dans de telles conditions n'est pas
neutre loin s'en faut
la situation difficile nombreux
établissements et praticiens
hospitaliers a été signalée à de
nombreuses reprises les suns par des
mois mais des années que la question qui
nous taraude le préoccupe aujourd'hui se
pose est du reste je ne pense pas que le
manque de réactivité de différents
ministres qui met notre système de santé
sous tension soit uniquement imputable à
un problème de simples et inertie
ce phénomène a par ailleurs connu une
accélération pour de multiples raisons
depuis quelque temps et singulièrement
depuis l'application tristement célèbre
loi hôpital patients santé territoires
qui ne renforce pas madame la ministre
c'est un constat loin s'en faut
ce que j'appellerais la facticité de
l'hôpital cette loire officialise de
fait que l'hôpital soit gérée comme une
entreprise privée
soucieuse et d'une forme de rentabilité
de l'effet mise aussi et ce n'est pas un
hasard si le nombre de praticiens qui
ont été formés hôpital qui ont passé
tout leur cursus y compris est d'un
niveau de l'internât et du clinica ont
fui en quelque sorte cet hôpital public
est d'ailleurs leur motivation a quitté
l'hôpital ne se résume en aucune façon à
la seule quête d'une meilleure
rémunération dans le privé
c'est donc fort logiquement que dans ce
conteste sommes sommes obligés de faire
appel à des professeurs professionnels
de santé qui ne sont pas issus du
circuit classique que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure et par ailleurs on s'est
satisfait on se satisfaisait jusqu'à
présent d'une sorte de fatalité
où on voit des médecins compétents qui
sont dotés de diplômes certes obtenu
hors union européenne mais qui sont
utilisés excusez moi le terme parfois
comme de simples variables d'ajustement
et sont en tout état de cause les
victimes patente de zones grises en
termes de réglementation
c'est donc une crise sérieuse que
traverse notre système de santé et qui
montre les dysfonctionnements profond de
l'hôpital qui en est incontestablement
un des révélateurs les plus pertinents
la fervente donc il revient aux
politiques de donner les moyens de
fonctionner et on ne saurait abandonner
son hôpital à des solutions de
recrutement juridique et financière
hasardeuse et qui sont du reste aux
limites de la légalité
nous affirmons donc également qu'on ne
saurait laisser les professions de santé
compétents en périphérie du système de
santé français avant très facilement de
les exclure en se donnant pour excuse de
ne pas avoir adapté les procédures trop
comprennent quand contraignantes
permettant de régulariser leurs
activités de lourdes incertitudes pèsent
sur l'avenir professionnel de ces
personnes là le mot est faible et au
delà faut-il souligner comme sainté fait
précédemment qu'elles sont sous payés
alors qu'elles accomplissent
parfaitement leur mission de service
public au quotidien avec compétence et
dévouement
circonstance aggravante au moment où je
parle
personne n'est en mesure de dire
exactement quelle est leur nombre la
contribution de ces médecins chirurgiens
dentistes sages femmes et pharmaciens et
régulièrement à juste titre qualifié
d'indispensable
il ya donc urgence adopté ce texte car
depuis le 1er janvier 2012
et malgré des instructions émanant de
votre ministère chère madame la ministre
on sait comment les choses sont
susceptibles d'évoluer en cas d'incident
ou d'accident médical qui mettrait en
difficulté
non seulement les établissements
concernés mais également les praticiens
qui sort qui serait à l'origine ont
impliqué dans cet incident en occident
il faut donc donner l'opportunité à
cette catégorie
professionnel de continuer à exercer
sereinement leur profession et si ce
texte ne résout rien
complètement sur le fond même s'il est
loin d'être parfait nous n'avons ni à
moins d'adopter en urgence les
professionnels santé titulaires de
diplômes non européen doit être autorisé
à continuer à exercer leurs fonctions
jusqu'en 2016
c'est l'objet de ce texte que nous
voterons pour autant nous pouvons pas
faire l'impasse mme la ministre sur les
raisons qui font que une des premières
puissances économiques mondiales soit
aujourd'hui incapable de former de
recruter des professionnels de santé
dans des conditions garantissant un
fonctionnement serein notre système
sanitaire
je ne reviendrai pas sur les moyens
suffisants qui sont donnés aux aliments
santé mais cela est évoqué aussi faut-il
s'interroger sur la pertinence de
numerus clausus qui a du reste fait
l'objet de textes de loi il ya quelques
années deux ans il me semble est
l'occasion de ce vote là beaucoup
d'entre eux s'étaient étonnés que du
fait que ce numerus clausus ne sont pas
connectés à une projection sur la
démographie médicale entre pays à 10 ou
20 ans nous en payons maintenant les
frais et sains tout état de cause
salissant du numerus clausus comment
justifier un mode de formation très
sélectif
alors que les besoins sont si importants
et les places pour vit dans des
conditions si problématique
quid à ces conditions de la ventilation
du corps médical entre l'urbain et le
rural entre l'hôpital public la médecine
de ville ou encore en faisant l'impasse
sur une féminisation croissante de cette
profession qui de fait se dirigera vers
du temps partiel et pénalisera le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital où dieu
merci le vide
vous permettrez madame la ministre pour
terminer après avoir évoqué ce problème
là sur les praticiens déjà diplômés
d'évoquer ce ceux qui sont étrangers qui
ont poursuivi leur cursus en france et
qui du fait de la circulaire guéant
on mange parle ne sont pas sûr
d'intégrer dans de bonnes conditions
notre système sanitaire merci mon cher
collègue la discussion générale est
close
nous passons donc la discussion des
articles à l'article la jeune fille si
je ne suis saisi d'aucun à moment
personne ne demande la parole
ce prénom madame une explication dois je
vais voter bien évidemment ce texte
parce que quand le feu est là il faut
appeler les pompiers
on joue le rôle de pompier à falloir
hilton l'incendié il ya un véritable
problème plusieurs d'entre nous l'ont
dit d'une manière très pertinente mais
il faut toujours et ceux ci me ride for
attend le dernier moment pour essayer de
résoudre des situations que tout le
monde connaît depuis très longtemps
alors effectivement l'instruction qu'il
était donnée là pour essayer de pouvoir
payer d'une part les médecins à diplôme
étranger
et puis aussi pour essayer de les
couvrir un peu sur le plan professionnel
parce que il ya toute cette dimension là
qui est sous jacent effectivement mais
c'est juridiquement très fragile moi je
crois que c'est ce qui me pose problème
ça fait des années et pas nécessairement
puis qu'il y a les 35 heures me sauver
des années j'entends ce problème est que
j'ai été conduit à le gérer dans
l'établissement et pas seulement dans
l'ordre puisque j'ai eu la chance
pendant quatre heures de gérer
l'établissement dans l'eau non non non
mais passe auprès de l'homme je parle de
ce que je connais bien aussi puisque
j'ai fait quatre ans comme chef
d'établissement en établissement je n'ai
jamais vu j'ai écouté écouter s'il vous
plaît un petit peu ça fera pas de mal
tout le monde d'écouter un peu le
terrain sur ce point là du moins il y a
depuis des années des déserts dans le
cadre de nos hôpitaux publics
il y à des déserts on l'a rappelé un
cd-r font que le quart en gros des
postes actuellement plein temps sont
vacants dans les hôpitaux
bon alors on va pouvoir me dire tout le
contraire c'est une réalité qui pose des
problèmes insurmontables
alors même que ces problèmes sont posés
en permanence à des structures de soins
et à des populations qui sort d'un des
milieux difficiles milieux ruraux et
parmi eux aux périphéries des grandes
villes
un jeu je connais un certain nombre
d'établissements j'ai aussi la chance de
gérer qui avait les problèmes aussi de
recrutement alors on peut pas continuer
comme ça il faut bien madame la ministre
comprenne à brac
qu'est-ce qu'on peut pas à la fois dans
ce pays à voir d'un côté au mieux
libérale des endroits où il ya une
surconsommation par une surconsommation
une sur-représentation médicale d'autre
il ya une sous représentation musicale
et parallèlement que les hôpitaux de
proximité dans tout le monde auquel tout
le monde
harcourt on va toujours au chu on n'est
pas tous prêts dans un chu
il n'y a à ce moment là des difficultés
pour une population qui est
vieillissante qui a des difficultés on
les envoie bien souvent et chu ça pose
problème
alors il ya effectivement un recours il
ya un recours à une main d'oeuvre que l'
on surexploite que l'on sous payent ils
sont surexploités et sous payés si on
veut pas dire d'ailleurs que les
médecins hospitaliers sont payés
confortablement on pourrait là aussi en
discuter et je suis prêt à en discuter
il faudra bien qu'à un moment ou à un
autre dans les mois à venir on prenne à
bras le corps ce problème et qu'on
apporte des solutions
il doit y avoir des solutions il faut
qu'il y ait des solutions pour pas
continuer on nous a dit le rapporteur
général nous a dit que depuis 1970 un
bon c'était les années où je démarrais
l'âge hôpitaux effectivement j'ai
pratiquement connu que ça ces problèmes
à gérer un aussi bien dans les urgences
que dans les services spécialité or il
ya des malades qui se font bien tremble
aussi en charge
il y a donc des difficultés faut prendre
à bras le corps dans le cadre de la
formation de ses médecins à diplôme
étranger
il faut savoir que par le biais des
stages c'est bien souvent le corps
médical en bim est de l'hexagone des
praticiens hospitaliers ou suite aux
universitaires qui pour les stages font
ces stages et on a des médecins
d'excellente qualité
il va falloir que là aussi on prenne pas
des solutions de pis-aller en les
laissant d'une manière encore provisoire
on va jusqu'en 2016
et puis après il faudra reconstituer à
nouveau et reconsidérer cette affaire ce
n'est pas possible
1 je crois que et là je demande à
monsieur le président de la commission
de l'amex qu'après notre rapport sur le
financement des établissements de soins
on regarde de près ce problème de
l'encadrement de nos hôpitaux
en france c'est un problème suffisamment
importants pour qu'on puisse pas
l'occulter et continuer à le mettre de
côté
merci d'une finition merci monsieur le
président à mon tour je voudrais saluer
la clarté du rapport de de notre
rapporteur de le féliciter pour la
célérité avec laquelle il a établi ce
rapport très intéressant d'ailleurs sur
un sujet ça a été dit par nous tous qui
existe depuis 40 ans et pour lequel nous
n'avons toujours pas trouvé de solution
et le sujet était gus je ne sais plus
qui a cité la situation de la région
nord pas de calais en particulier du pas
de calais ou s'il n'y avait pas ces
étudiants qui ne rendait autant service
avec autant de compétences autant
d'investissements les listes de liste de
garde nos hôpitaux n'est ce ne se
créerait pas et les hôpitaux généraux
seraient fermés et je crois que c'est
malheureusement là le cas dans la très
grande majorité de nos hôpitaux généraux
sur l'ensemble du territoire avec des
territoires qui sont plus touchés que
d'autres
et avec également des spécialités qui
sont plus concernés que d'autres nous
avons cité bien évidemment le secteur de
l'urgence on peut citer le secteur de la
radiologie
le secteur de la chirurgie l'anesthésié
de l'obstétrique
en fait toutes ces spécialités j'ai
envie de dire que pour autant nous ne
devons pas avoir une approche que tu
elite ariste vis-à-vis de ces hommes c
et des femmes pour lesquelles nous
devons traiter du sujet avec respect
ceux que nous ne leur devons c'est le
respect c'est le respect quand nous
savons par ailleurs qu'ils sont
effectivement ça vient d'être exposé
avec beaucoup de fougue mais avec
beaucoup de réalisme par jacky le menn
quand ils sont sous traités n'hésitons
pas à le dire quand ils n'ont pas de
définition de profil de carrière et ça
madame la ministre j'espère que avant la
fin de notre comment dire de notre
réunion nous allons vous allez pouvoir
nous donner des informations sur le
sujet et quand par ailleurs ils sont pas
reconnus y compris sur le plan financier
à la juste valeur pour le travail qu'ils
fournissent
avec le prétexte qu'ils sont comment
dire cela dépendance de médecins
praticiens que je ne dénigre pas bien
évidemment mais dont on sait qu'ils ne
sont en général pas sur le terrain ce
qui peut poser d'ailleurs par ailleurs
des problèmes de responsabilité
donc il est vraiment urgentissime de
trouver une situation correcte à statut
correct assez à ses hommes à ces femmes
qui nous rendre service sans occulter
d'ailleurs le sujet de coopération
internationale de qualité que nous avons
nous devons avoir avec les pays qui nous
permettent de les accueillir
qui sait personne ne serait sans doute
utile également dans leur pays quand
certains de nos collègues l'ont dit non
seulement nous accueillons ces étudiants
à titre étranger j'aimerais d'ailleurs
que le gouvernement soit plus amène le
vis-à-vis d'eux mais nous allons nous
faisons aussi de la prospection pour
aller les chercher et pour les allées
les inclure dans nos établissements et
je voudrais pas faire de mauvais esprit
mais il ne faudrait pas que ce soit un
moyen pour nos établissements publics
qui sont en grande difficulté financière
de trouver là des solutions qui
permettraient peut-être de faire des
économies à bon compte
par ailleurs le ca a été dit par bon
nombre d'entre nous aussi le sujet de
l'accueil de ces médecins qui exercent
aujourd'hui à titre étranger pose de
façon beaucoup plus structurelle le
problème de l'attractivité des carrières
hospitalières à l'hôpital public pour
l'ensemble de nos collègues de nos
collègues praticiens et j'ai envie de
dire ça n'est pas uniquement un problème
financier c'est aussi la nécessité de
pouvoir reconnaître c'est un problème
financier j'en vois qui au pic du c'est
aussi un problème financier mais ça
n'est pas que cela on sait très bien
quand on commence une carrière
hospitalière à l'hôpital public on note
qu on n'aura pas le même niveau de
rémunération que dans le secteur privé
et ça n'est pas nouveau mais ce qui est
important aussi de prendre en compte
c'est la reconnaissance du niveau de
responsabilité qu'ils exercent
et puis je le dis aussi et les lois se
succédant mais la loi hpst ne niant pas
améliorer les choses
il faut arrêter d'avoir une chape de
plomb administrative qui je le dis
empêche de travailler
il y en a dont on voit des praticiens
qui quittent l'hôpital public parce
qu'en fait ils n'en peuvent plus de ne
pas pouvoir travailler correctement et
librement et exercer avec leurs équipes
médicales et paramédicales leur art de
la façon la plus satisfaisante possible
alors je ne crois pas que le la
variation du comment du numerus clausus
suffira à résoudre tous les problèmes
mais nous avons vraiment là aa jr tous
là où nous sommes et j'espère que
d'ailleurs les prochains rendez vous
électoraux que nous aurons nous
permettront aux uns et aux autres
d'exprimer les solutions que nous
proposons en sachant que elles ne sont
pas simples bien évidemment car pour
avoir longtemps discuté avec les
syndicats médicaux les médecins
hospitaliers fallait ont toujours refusé
une différenciation de comment dire de
différents fin de de reconnaissance de
la spécialité en fonction de la
pénibilité
ah ça c'est assez quand même un sujet
qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit et qui fait
que ça permet parfois d'avoir des
difficultés de reconnaître peut-être des
carrières différencier à l'hôpital donc
le sujet n'est pas simple mais néanmoins
il me semble urgentissime à résoudre et
puis enfin notre rapporteur a évoqué
j'ai à dire la non ce qui semble être la
non ce miracle pour nos praticiens
hospitaliers qui effectivement croule il
faut le reconnaître d'ailleurs par
manque de personnel médical et
paramédical mais par manque de personnel
sous le travail et pour lesquels nous
n'arrivons pas soit à leur permettre de
récupérer de la pénibilité de leur
travail soit de pouvoir être être
rémunéré alors c'est vrai personne le
contexte le contest pardon que c'est en
partie le résultat de l'application des
35 heures mais pas seulement
mais pas seulement c'est aussi la
reconnaissance de la pénibilité des
métiers qu'ils exercent et de l'exigence
des conditions sécurité qu'ils doivent
pouvoir fournir aux patients et je
rappelle quand même que les dispositifs
qui nous pose problème aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas ça n'a pas été mis en place
par un gouvernement de gauche a été mis
en place par un gouvernement de droite
par un ministre
pour lequel j'ai beaucoup de respect
même si je ne partage pas ses
orientations politiques à savoir jean
françois mattei et qui faute sans doute
d'étude d'impact approfondie n'a pas
mesuré
j'ai à dire les conséquences des
dispositions qu'il a prises pour le
statut de de ces praticiens hospitaliers
tout cela pour dire que et en conclusion
je crois que beaucoup de nos collègues
l'ont dit qu'il est urgent à la fois
pour en revenir au sujet premier de
donner un statut digne à nos médecins et
qui exerce à titre étranger de les
sortir de la fragilité de leur statut la
stabilité professionnelle dans laquelle
ils sont de trouver comment dire les
solutions d'une d'une attractivité pour
l'hôpital public retrouver et puis enfin
également de faire en sorte que nos
hôpitaux publics fonctionnent autrement
que ce qu'il fonctionne aujourd'hui
madame moi je m'en suis le président
madame le ministre mes chers collègues
pour ma part je vois très bien
évidemment ces deux articles mais je
veux néanmoins profiter de l'occasion
qui m'est donnée aujourd'hui pour
dénoncer moi ce fameux numerus clausus
sens qu'elle nous aurions des médecins
de famille dans nos campagnes des
spécialistes dans nos villes et des
praticiens diplôme français dans nos
hôpitaux
le numerus clausus est également un mode
de sélection basés sur les mathématiques
et la physique en première année de
médecine pousse les jeunes français à
s'expatrier pour aller suivre leurs
études à l'étranger souvent en roumanie
ou ailleurs
alors le numerus clausus je pense qu'il
est tout de même en grande partie
responsable de la disparition des
médecins en zone rurale et c'est
toujours à cause de ce fameux numerus
clausus que nos hôpitaux recrute des
médecins étrangers qui nous soignent
avec grande compétence bien sûr il faut
le souligner nous les en remercions mais
dont les diplômes ne sont pas reconnus
ni par la france ni par l'europe alors
on repose parfois que former des
médecins coûte cher surtout lorsque ces
derniers sont des femmes
et oui qui ont des femmes qui ont selon
certains encore la curieuse idée
de vouloir fonder une famille avec leurs
enfants tout en travaillant parfois à
temps partiel pendant quelques années
vous voyez madame le ministre
cette proposition de loi met l'accent
sur de nombreuses questions
le malaise est profond j'espère qu'un
jour c'est quand même un comble la
politique sera à venir au secours de ces
professions médicales que je pense bien
malade dans notre pays merci monsieur le
noir et le président madame laminé qui
reconnaît que je serais intervenu en
explications de vote à l'issue de la
discussion mais comme tout le monde
semble vouloir le faire maintenant que
je suis le mouvement
j'ai apprécié les propos qui ont été
tenus par plusieurs de nos collègues
quant au respect que nous devons et que
nous manifestons à l'égard de ces
médecins dont il est question
aujourd'hui
j'ajoute pas seulement le respect la
reconnaissance nous avons tous dans nos
hôpitaux dans nos territoires la part
qu'ils prennent depuis très longtemps à
la permanence des soins l'accueil des
malades et des blessés
c'est la raison pour laquelle depuis
longtemps mais comme nous tous
je ne cherche pas du tout à me mettre en
valeur nous sommes sensibles à leur
situation
j'ajoute pays il a été beaucoup question
des départements donne je suis vraiment
très sensible à l'intérêt que beaucoup
de nos collègues portent à ce très beau
département
j'ai noté dans le rapport de monsieur
dominique 73 % des nouveaux inscrits à
l'ordre des médecins étaient étrangers
dans l'orne
c'est l'un des départements violet
vérifier où il y en a le plus les hommes
d'ailleurs en ayant 100%
alors lorsque la question a été posée
d'une façon très forte au cours de l'été
dernier je me suis rapproché de xavier
bertrand et à l'époque il m'a associé à
la rédaction de l'amendement du fameux
amendement qui a été votée dans le cadre
du projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale
nous pensions que la mission était
accomplie
l'amendement d'ailleurs été encore
améliorée sénat peu de temps après et il
ya eu l'addition du conseil
constitutionnel je ne vais pas la
commenter
et donc aujourd'hui vraiment
je me réjouis premièrement que le
gouvernement et faciliter l'examen de
cette proposition de loi qui vient de
l'âme de collègues amis de l'assemblée
nationale jean pierre door que ce texte
devienne rapidement et je me félicite
également de voir qu'une belle unanimité
se dégage sur notre hémicycle en faveur
de cette adoption le plus rapidement
possible le texte examiné par le sénat
hier a été adoptée à l'unanimité lé
médecin titulaire d'un diplôme obtenu
dans un état non membre de l'union
européenne voit donc leur autorisation
d'exercer prolongée jusqu'à 2016
tout de suite le ministre de l'intérieur
claude guéant et le président du groupe
socialiste du sénat françois rebsamen
débattent autour du thème de la sécurité
dont à l'heure du choix
très bonne journée à tous sur public
sénat